I would like to say that my favorite
[ __ ] you did was the Tucker the toe
sucker [ __ ] yeah everybody everybody
want me to come back and do another one
of them with that guy yeah everybody's
like man do it do another one but I'm
like they were what they they listen man
I think that dude's from my hometown too
I'm from Phoenix I'm pretty sure that's
where he's from everybody listen
everybody always says like you know
bring back the confrontational ones or
do this one or do that one but I'm like
they were organic when they happened
this ain't no script yeah you can't run
that back again with that same energy
not even that but like I'm not trying to
come back like that [ __ ] happened the
way that it happened like I didn't plan
that [ __ ] it wasn't no okay we're gonna
go in here we're gonna get the bumping
heads and all if a [ __ ] say
some more weird [ __ ] or some off the
wall [ __ ] hey I don't agree with that I
think that I'm older bro you have to
understand something like a lot of these
people that and I've said this before on
other podcasts like a lot of the people
that I interview
um um 12 13 years their senior bro so
it's a huge gap in the mental capacity
of what I hold and what they hold
they're just now getting around to it
bro they're getting their nipples wet
you know what I'm saying or I'm saying
[ __ ] getting harder like they
just getting around to doing something
like that like I've been around the
block homie seven eight ninety thousand
[ __ ] times so like these these are
kids to me I'm saying but we don't we
don't hold that respect no more for
people that come from you know hey man
I've been here before you I know better
yeah I've seen some things yeah they
don't listen to that it's all [ __ ] you
you just oh like yo yo
yo yo mindset or what you got to offer
ain't gonna get me nowhere because today
knowledge isn't I said it earlier today
and it was crazy because I thought about
I'm like not people don't like knowledge
because you can't spend it
um it's not it's not a tangible currency
tangible currency they can't walk in the
mall and spend the knowledge you give
them they're not looking at it that hey
it can look out for you in the long run
yeah they're not looking at it like that
man that's some real [ __ ] you know what
I'm saying they're not looking at it
like that that's why knowledge has been
the book that's the the lowest of the
low of value right now on in currency
and it should be the highest it should
be the number one most priceless thing I
think knowledge and time old I'm saying
like but come on man like even with even
with it runs hand in hand yeah for
knowledge and time but it's
like people need to really look at it
like that knowledge is everything and
what you can take in what you can how
much of it you can consume it's
Priceless it'll help you in the long run
do you feel like um you're kind of
experiencing because I feel like you've
had some really dope deep conversations
on your podcasts that are [ __ ]
incredible
but the [ __ ] that always goes viral is
like when you get into one of these
confrontations that goes crazy and like
it's like okay that [ __ ] is cool and
like you said it was an organic
conference yeah like it's not like
you're planning that [ __ ] to go run back
right I don't want to run that back
that's fake to me you know what I'm
saying like that's not how it landed
everything happened the way that it
happened you got to catch it real life
in real time 100 man
is there anything like um that you feel
like you've improved upon since you
started the podcast like just in terms
of like I I think I've improved a lot
like in you know just trying to take my
time more with things but you know I
feel like people only critique
themselves to the viewer but you're
still watching you what you should want
this to be organic you should not want
this to be because your comments change
the narrative now and it's what it is
now that then got watered down that
means everybody can [ __ ] do it right
and not everybody can do it so sit the
[ __ ] back let me grab the steering wheel
let me drive don't try to put your hand
on it you're turning right I'm turning
left we're bound to [ __ ] crash don't
do me got you you know what I'm saying
let us take the steering wheel let us do
what we're doing that's what makes it
captivating real conversation and I've
said it before with overall real people
and like I think people obviously
gravitate to you because [ __ ] those are
some of the highest uh view counts on a
software underbelly are your interviews
like people obviously really gravitate
to you because I think you're pretty
unapologetically I mean I'll say this I
feel like there's some people that
probably whoop me but they were on some
weird [ __ ] like it was some it wasn't
like hey people hate you they're gonna
watch you as well like yeah people hate
you because they want to have something
to talk about like I like to go back to
like some of my interviews I've done
even though I got a lot of them that's
done numbers gold but some of the ones
that I really was like this was a good
one right here was it was it had
information it had knowledge it was
showing you where this person's been
where they're where they're at today and
where they're headed it's it's got all
of the the missing pieces of the puzzle
to become a masterpiece you know a one
of one and a lot of people won't though
they won't watch that one as much as
they'll watch the confrontational one
because they like drama they like
confrontation they don't want to learn
anything that's why I told you knowledge
is at an all-time low you should be
wanting to take this [ __ ] and run with
this apply it to your life somebody's
trying to give it up to you take that
[ __ ] man because ain't [ __ ] for free in
this world but an [ __ ] but not say
before man sometimes you can't even get
that for free ain't that the truth for
real what's a couple of the interviews
that you wish more people would have
watched
um bet you're like man this one was
special like I really wish this would
have went crazier for the right reasons
there was a there was a couple man you
know
um
one of the first ones that I did that
didn't have any confrontation my boy
cookie man uh Tookie blunt he owns a
dispensary out in the bay and you know
he went through hell man business
partners robbing him like he teared up
like he was saying because he really
trusted these people you know what I'm
saying they have to bounce back by
himself right and really like try to
bring it to the Forefront to where he's
sitting there now telling his story like
it was it was definitely captivating it
was I I feel like this man like there's
a lot of them that just need to be
watched like don't just look for the
controversy come and get the knowledge
too because to me there's countless ones
I feel like I've done that they deserved
more that's fair you know what I'm
saying they deserved more man but hey
who am I that would make me I can't
critique that because that would turn me
to a viewer and I just want them to do
what they do organically but just don't
just always look for the drama look for
some knowledge too and something you can
gain because that time that you sat
there and even just watched that
[ __ ] or somebody get into it you
could have spent learning something as
well that's real you don't get your time
back I don't care also 20 [ __ ]
minutes I also feel like even when
you're getting in it into it with people
it's almost from like a place of like
frustration where it's like yo are you
[ __ ] know your place of passion right
right because all and all in all I give
a [ __ ] about people bro and you know
sometimes you got to give people tough
love you got to tell them what they need
to hear versus what they want to hear
everybody's been cushioned by that man
we've cushioned ourselves with that here
in America bro and we gotta stop doing
that to each other we got to stop lying
to each other and overall to ourselves
I feel you on that if we don't bet come
on bro when do we when do we break that
cycle it seems like it's getting softer
it's not getting any stronger